at five o'clock if you get caught with
illegal fireworks you will now face
heftier fines today county commissioners
approved increasing those penalties now
the first offense will be 500 dollars
joe moeller joining us now from the
clark county government center a
government building with some of the
other changes as well joe
it's a problem we see year after year
especially around the 4th of july we all
see those fireworks that light up the
sky now the fire department wants to
increase the fines associated with
illegal fireworks these fireworks light
up the sky and sometimes they come down
causing some damage
this is the sky over las vegas on the
fourth of july we were
sleeping you know and then me and my
wife was boom boom we heard some noise
gabrielle ramos lives a few houses down
from a home that looks like this we
start
yelling at each other get out let's get
out he says this past june illegal
fireworks caused the north las vegas
home to go up in flames killing several
pets it's a prime example of the dangers
of fireworks it could be me or the
neighbor the clark county fire
department is working to curb the use of
illegal fireworks and stop dangerous
situations proposal was for us to
increase our fines fines in clark county
areas would go up hundreds of dollars it
would be 500 dollars for a first offense
and a thousand dollars for a second if
the fireworks are under 100 pounds if
over it would be five thousand dollars
and if over five thousand pounds you are
looking at a fine of ten thousand
dollars we want to try to discourage as
much as possible
the effects of these illegal fireworks
especially
the fires and the injuries that occur
the ordinance passed with a yes vote
from every commissioner because if i can
save one person's home or
the child's hand last year that was
blown off by fireworks i'm going to do
anything i can brahmo says he made his
own policy for his family following the
scary incident fireworks have not
allowed my family from now on i said no
it's kind of dangerous
the county commissioner kirkpatrick
urged people to report illegal use of
fireworks uh do not call the three one
one line which so many people do she
urges people to go online and report it
to icebyfireworks.com
reporting live this evening in downtown
las vegas joe muller live local now